The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Last time, we began
the discussion of the
z-transform.
As with the Laplace transform
in continuous time, we
developed it as a
generalization
of the Fourier transform.
The expression that we got for
the z-transform is the sum
that I indicate here.
We also briefly talked about
an inverse z-transform
integral and some other informal
methods of computing
the inverse z-transform.
But we focused in particular
on the relationship between
the z-transform and the Fourier
transform, pointing
out first of all that the
z-transform, when we choose
the magnitude of
z equal to 1--
so the magnitude of z of the
form e to the j omega--
just simply reduces
to the Fourier
transform of the sequence.
Then, in addition, we explored
the z-transform for z, a more
general complex number.
In the discrete time z-transform
case, we expressed
that complex number in polar
form as r e to the j omega,
and recognize that the
z-transform expression in fact
corresponds to the Fourier
transform of the sequence
exponentially weighted.
Because of the exponential
weighting, the z-transform
converges for some values of
r corresponding to some
exponential waiting, and perhaps
not for others, and
that led to a notion which
corresponded to the region of
convergence associated
with the z-transform.
We talked some about properties
of the region of
convergence, particularly
in relation to
the pole-zero pattern.
Now, they z-transform has a
number of important and useful
properties, just as the Laplace
transform does.
As one part of this lecture,
what we'll want to do is
exploit some of these properties
in the context of
systems described by linear
constant coefficient
difference equations.
These particular properties that
play an important role in
that context are the properties
that I indicate here.
In particular, there is--
as with continuous time--
a linearity property that tells
us that the z-transform
of a linear combination of
sequences is the same linear
combination of the z-transforms,
a shifting
property that indicates that
the z-transform of x of n
shifted is the z transform of x
of n multiplied by a factor
z to the minus n 0.
Then the convolution property
for which the z-transform of a
convolution of sequences is the
product of the associated
z-transforms.
With all of these properties, of
course, there is again the
issue of what the associated
region of convergence is in
comparison with the region
of convergence of
the original sequences.
That is an issue that's
addressed somewhat more in the
text and let's not
go into it here.
With the convolution property,
the convolution property as in
continuous time, of course,
provides a mechanism for
dealing with linear time
invariant systems.
In particular, in the time
domain a linear time invariant
system is described through
convolution--
namely, the output is the
convolution of the input and
the impulse response.
Because of the convolution
property associated with the
z-transform, the z-transform
of the output is the
z-transform of the input
times the z-transform
of the impulse response.
Again, very much the same as
what we had in continuous time
and also what we had in the
context of the discussion with
the Fourier transform.
In fact, because of the
relationship between the
z-transform and the Fourier
transform, the z-transform of
the impulse response evaluated
on the unit circle--
in other words, for the
magnitude of z equal to 1--
in fact corresponds
to the frequency
response of the system.
More generally, when we talk
about the z-transform of the
impulse response, we will refer
to it as the system
function associated
with the system.
Now, the convolution property
and these other properties, as
I indicated, we will find
useful in talking about
systems which are described by
linear constant coefficient
difference equations, and in
fact, we'll do that shortly.
But first what I'd like to do is
to continue to focus on the
system function for linear time
invariant systems, and
make a couple of comments that
tie back to some things that
we said in the last lecture
relating to the relationship
between the region of
convergence of a system, or--
I'm sorry, the region of
convergence of a z-transform--
and the issue of where that is
in relation to the poles of
the z-transform.
In particular, we can draw some
conclusions tying back to
that discussion about the pole
locations of the system
function in relation to whether
the system is stable
and whether the system
is causal.
In particular, recall from one
of the early lectures way back
when that stability for a system
corresponded to the
statement that the
impulse response
is absolutely summable.
Furthermore, when we talked
about the Fourier transform,
the Fourier transform of a
sequence converges if the
sequence is absolutely
summable.
So in fact, the condition for
stability of a system and the
condition for convergence of the
Fourier transform of its
impulse response are the same
condition, namely absolute
summability.
Now what does this mean?
What it means is that if the
Fourier transform converges,
that means that the z-transform
converges on the
unit circle.
Consequently, if the system
is stable, then the system
function, the z-transform or
the impulse response, must
also converge on the
unit circle.
In other words, the impulse
response must have a Fourier
transform that converges.
So for a stable system, then,
the region of convergence of
the system function must
include the unit
circle in the z-plane.
So we see how stability relates
to the location of the
region of convergence, and we
can also relate causality to
the region of convergence.
In particular, we know that if
a system is causal, then the
impulse response
is right-sided.
For a sequence that's
right-sided, the region of
convergence of its z-transform
must be outside
the outermost pole.
So for causality, the region of
convergence of the system
function must be outside
the outermost pole.
For stability, the region of
convergence must include the
unit circle, and we can also
then draw from that the
conclusion that if we have a
system that's causal unstable,
then all poles must be inside
the unit circle because of the
fact that the poles must--
because of the fact that the
region of convergence must be
outside the outermost
pole and has to also
include the unit circle.
So for example, if we had let's
say a system with a
system function as I indicate
here with the algebraic
expression for the system
function being the expression
that I indicate here with the
pole at z equals a third and
another pole at z equals 2
and a zero at the origin.
If, in fact, the system was
causal, corresponding to an
impulse response that's
right-sided, this then would
be the region of convergence
of the system function.
Alternatively, if I knew that
the system was stable, then I
know that the region of
convergence must include the
unit circle, and so this would
be then the region of
convergence.
And what you might now want to
ask yourselves is if instead
the region of convergence for
the system function is this,
then is the system causal?
That's the first question.
The second question is
is the system stable?
Remembering that for causality,
the region of
convergence must be outside the
outermost pole, and for
stability it must include
the unit circle.
Now what I'd like to do is look
at the properties of the
z-transform, and in particular
exploit these properties in
the context of systems that
are described by linear
constant coefficient difference
equations.
The three basic properties that
play a key role in that
discussion are the linearity
property, the shifting
property, and the convolution
property.
These, then, are the properties
that I want to exploit.
So let's do that by first
looking at a first order
difference equation.
In the case of a first order
difference equation, which
I've written as I
indicate here--
no terms on the right hand side,
but we could have terms
of course, in general--
y of n minus ay of n minus
1 equals x of n.
We can use the linearity
property, so that if we take
the z-transform of both sides of
this expression, that will
then be the z-transform of this
term plus the z-transform
of this term.
So using those properties and
together with the shifting
property, the property that
tells us that the z-transform
of y of n minus 1 is z to the
minus 1 times the z-transform
of y of n, we then convert the
difference equation to an
algebraic expression.
And we can solve this algebraic
expression for the
z-transform of the output
in terms of the
z-transform of the input.
Now what we know from the
convolution property is that
for a system, the z-transform
of the output is the system
function times the z-transform
of the input.
So this factor that we have,
then, must correspond to the
system function, or equivalently
the z-transform
of the impulse response
of the system.
In fact, then, if we have this
z-transform, we could figure
out what the impulse response of
the system is by computing
or determining what the inverse
z-transform, except
for the fact that expression is
an algebraic expression and
doesn't yet totally specify
the z-transform because we
don't yet know what the region
of convergence is.
How do we get the region
of convergence?
Well, we have the same issue
here as we had with the
Laplace transform--
namely, the point that the
difference equation tells us,
in essence, what the algebraic
expression is for the system
function, but doesn't specify
the region of convergence.
That is specified by either
explicitly, because one way or
another we know what the
impulse response is, or
implicitly, because we know
certain properties of the
system, such as causality
and or stability.
If I, let's say, imposed on this
system, in addition to
the difference equation, the
condition of causality, then
what that requires is that
the impulse response be
right-sided or the region of
convergence be outside the
outermost pole.
So, for this example that would
require, then, that the
region of convergence correspond
to the magnitude of
z greater than the
magnitude of a.
What you might think about is
whether I would get the same
condition if I required
instead that
the system be stable.
Furthermore, you could think
about the question of whether
I could specify or impose on
this system that it be both
stable and causal.
The real issue-- and let me
just kind of point to it--
is that the answer to those
questions relate to whether
the magnitude of a is less than
1 or the magnitude of a
is greater than 1.
If the magnitude of a is less
than 1 and I specify
causality, that will also mean
that the system is stable.
In any case, given this region
of convergence, then the
impulse response is the inverse
transform of that
z-transform, which is a
to the n times u of n.
Now let's look at a second order
equation, and there's a
very similar strategy.
For the second order equation,
the one that I've picked is of
this particular form, and I've
written the coefficients
parametrically as I indicate
here for a specific reason,
which we'll see shortly.
Again, I can apply the
z-transform to this
expression, and I've skipped an
algebraic step or two here.
When I do this, then, again I
use the linearity property and
the shifting property, and I
end up with this algebraic
expression.
If I now solve that to express
y of z in terms of x of z and
a function of z, then
this is what I get
for the system function.
So this is now a second order
system function, and we'll
have two zeroes at the origin
and it will have two poles.
Again, there's the question of
what we assume about the
region of convergence--
I haven't specified that yet.
But if we, let's say, assume
that the system is causal,
which I will tend to do, then
that means that the region of
convergence is outside
the outermost pole.
Now, where are the poles?
Well, let me just kind
of indicate that if--
and you can verify this
algebraically at your leisure--
that if the cosine theta term is
less than 1, then the roots
of this polynomial
will be complex.
And in fact, the poles
are at r e to the
plus or minus j theta.
So for cosine theta less than 1,
then the poles are complex,
and the complex poles at an
angle theta and with a
distance from the origin equal
to the parameter r.
In fact, let's just
look at that.
What I show here is the
pole zero pattern.
Assuming that r is less than
1, and that cosine theta is
less than 1, and we have a
complex pole pair shown here--
now if we assume that the system
was causal, that means
that the region of convergence
is outside these poles.
That would then include the unit
circle, which means that
the system is also stable.
In fact, as long as the reach
of convergence includes the
unit circle, we can also talk
about the frequency response
of the system--
namely, we can evaluate
the system
function on the unit circle.
We, in fact, evaluated the
Fourier transform associated
with this pole zero
pattern last time.
Recall that the frequency
response, then, is one that
has a resonant character with
the resonant peak being
roughly in the vicinity of the
angle of the pole location.
As the parameter r varies--
let's say, as r gets smaller--
this peak tends to broaden.
As r gets closer to
1, the resonance
tends to get sharper.
This is now a look at the
z-transform, and we see very
strong parallels to the
Laplace transform.
In fact, throughout the
course, I've tried to
emphasize--
and it just naturally
happens--
that there are very strong
relationships and parallels
between continuous time
and discrete time.
In fact, at one point we
specifically mapped from
continuous time to discrete
time when we talked about
discrete time processing of
continuous time signals.
What I'd like to do now is turn
our attention to another
very important reason for
mapping from continuous time
to discrete time, and in the
process of doing this, what
we'll need to do is exploit
fairly heavily the insight,
intuition, and procedures that
we've developed for the
Laplace transform and
the z-transform.
Specifically, what I would like
to begin is a discussion
relating to mapping continuous
time filters to discrete time
filters, or continuous time
system functions to discrete
time system functions.
Now, why would we
want to do that?
Well, there are at least several
reasons for wanting to
map continuous time filters
to discrete time filters.
One, of course, is the fact that
in some situations what
we're interested in doing is
processing continuous time
signals with discrete
time systems--
or, said another way, simulate
continuous time systems with
discrete time systems.
So it would be natural in a
setting like that to think of
mapping the desired continuous
time filter to a
discrete time filter.
So that's one very important
context.
There's another very important
context in which this is done,
and that is in the context or
for the purpose of exploiting
established design procedures
for continuous time filters.
The point is the following.
We may or may not be processing
a sample continuous
time signal with our discrete
time filter-- it may just be
discrete time signals that
we're working with.
But in that situation, still,
we need to design the
appropriate discrete
time filter.
Historically, there is a very
rich history associated with
design of continuous
time filters.
In many cases, it's possible
and very worthwhile and
efficient to take those designs
and map them to
discrete time designs to use
them as discrete time filters.
So, another very important
reason for talking about the
kinds of mappings that we will
be going into is to simply
take advantage of what has been
done historically in the
continuous time case.
Now, if we want to map
continuous time filters to
discrete time filters, then in
continuous time, we're talking
about a system function
and an associated
differential equation.
In discrete time, there is the
corresponding system function
and the corresponding
difference equation.
Basically what we want to do is
generate from a continuous
time system in some way a
discrete time system that
meets an associated set of
desired specifications.
Now, there are certain
constraints that it's
reasonable and important to
impose on whatever kinds of
mappings we use.
Obviously, we want a mapping
that will take our continuous
time system function
and map it to a
discrete time system function.
Correspondingly in the time
domain, there is a continuous
time impulse response that
maps to the associated
discrete time impulse
response.
These are more or
less natural.
The two that are important and
sometimes easy to lose sight
of are the two that
I indicate here.
In particular, if we are mapping
a continuous time
filter with, let's say, a
desired or desirable frequency
response to a discrete time
filter and we would like to
preserve the good qualities of
that frequency response as we
look at the discrete time
frequency response, then it's
important what happens in the
s-plane for the continuous
time filter along the j omega
axis relate in a nice way to
what happens in the z-plane
around the unit circle,
because it's this over here that
represents the frequency
response in continuous time
and this contour over here
that represents the frequency
response in discrete time.
So that's an important
property.
We want to kind of the
j omega axis to
map to the unit circle.
Another more or less natural
condition to impose is a
condition that if we are assured
in some way that our
continuous time filter is
stable, then we would like to
concentrate on design procedures
that more or less
preserve that and will give
us stable digital filters.
So these are kind of reasonable
conditions to
impose on the procedure.
What I'd like to do in the
remainder of this lecture is
look at two common procedures
for mapping continuous time
filters to discrete
time filters.
The first one that I want to
talk about is one that, in
fact, is very frequently used,
and also one that, as we'll
see for a variety of reasons,
is highly undesirable.
The second is one that is also
frequently used, and as we'll
see is, in certain situations,
very desirable.
The first one that I want to
talk about is the more or less
intuitive simple procedure
of mapping a differential
equation to a difference
equation by simply replacing
derivatives by differences.
The idea is that a derivative is
more or less a difference,
and there's some dummy parameter
capital T that I've
thrown in here, which I won't
focus too much on.
But in any case, this seems
to have some plausibility.
If we take the differential
equation and do this with all
the derivatives, both in terms
of y of t and x of t, what
we'll end up with is a
difference equation.
Now what we can use are the
properties of the Laplace
transform and the z-transform
to see what this means in
terms of a mapping--
in particular, using the
differentiation property for
Laplace transforms.
In the Laplace transform domain,
we would have this.
Using the properties for the
z-transform, the z-transform
of this expression
would be this.
So, in effect, what it says is
that every place in the system
function or in the differential
equation that we
would be multiplying by s when
Laplace transformed.
In the difference equation,
we would be
multiplying by this factor.
In fact, what this means is
that the mapping from
continuous time to discrete time
corresponds to taking the
system function and replacing
s wherever we see it by 1
minus z to the minus 1 over
capital T. So if we have a
system function in continuous
time and we map it to a
discrete time system function
this way by replacing
derivatives by differences,
then that corresponds to
replacing s by 1 minus z to the
minus 1 over capital T.
Now we'll see shortly what this
mapping actually means
more specifically in relating
the s-plane to the z-plane.
Let me just quickly, because I
want to refer to this, also
point to another procedure
very much like backward
differences which corresponds
to replacing derivatives not
by the backward differences
that I just showed, but by
forward differences.
In that case, then, the
mapping corresponds to
replacing s by z to the minus
1 over capital T. It looks
very similar to the
previous case.
So there the relationship
between these system functions
is what I indicate here.
Let's just take a look at what
those mappings correspond to
when we look at this
specifically in the s-plane
and in the z-plane.
What I show here is the s-plane,
and of course it's
things on the left half of the
s-plane, poles on the left
half of the s-plane that would
guarantee stability.
It's the j omega axis the tells
us about the frequency
response, and in the z-plane
it's the unit circle that
tells us about the frequency
response.
Things inside the unit circle,
or poles inside the unit
circle, that guarantee
stability.
Now the mapping from s-plane to
the z-plane corresponding
to replacing derivatives by
backward differences in fact
can be shown to correspond to
mapping the j omega axis not
to the unit circle, but to the
little circle that I show
here, which is inside
the unit circle.
The left half of the
s-plane maps to the
inside of that circle.
What does that mean?
That means that if we have a
really good frequency response
characteristic along this
contour in the s-plane, we'll
see that same frequency
response
along this little circle.
That's not the one that
we want, though--
we would like to see that same
frequency response around the
unit circle.
To emphasize this point even
more-- suppose, for example,
that we had a pair of poles in
our continuous time system
function that looked
like this.
Then, where they're likely to
end up in the z-plane is
inside the unit circle,
of course.
But if the poles here are close
to the j omega axis,
that means that these poles will
be close to this circle,
but in fact might be very far
away from the unit circle.
What would happen, then, is
that if we saw in the
continuous time filter a very
sharp resonance, the discrete
time filter in fact might very
well have that resonance
broadened considerably because
the poles are so far away from
the unit circle.
Now, one plus with this method,
and it's about the
only one, is the fact that the
left half of the s-plane maps
inside the unit circle-- in
fact, inside a circle inside
the unit circle, and so
stability is always
guaranteed.
Let me just quickly mention,
and you'll have a chance to
look at this a little more
carefully in the video course
manual, that for forward
differences instead of
backward differences, this
contour in the s-plane maps to
a line in the z-plane, which is
a line tangent to the unit
circle, and in fact is the
line that I showed there.
So not only are forward
differences equally bad in
terms of the issue of whether
they map from the j omega axis
to the unit circle, but they
have a further difficulty
associated with them, which is
the difficulty they may not
and generally don't guarantee
stability.
Now, that's one method, and one,
as I indicated, that's
often used partly
because it seems
so intuitively plausible.
What you can see is that by
understanding carefully the
issues and the techniques of
Laplace and z-transforms, you
can begin to see what some of
the difficulties with those
methods are.
The next method that I'd like
to talk about is a method
that, in fact, is very
commonly used.
It's a very important, useful
method, which kind of can be
motivated by thinking along
the lines of mapping the
continuous time filter to a
discrete time filter in such a
way that the shape of the
impulse response is
preserved--
and, in fact, more specifically
so that the
discrete time impulse response
corresponds to samples of the
continuous time impulse
response.
And this is a method that's
referred to as impulse
invariance.
So what impulse invariance
corresponds to is designing
the filter in such a way that
the discrete time filter
impulse response is simply
a sample version of the
continuous time filter impulse
response with a sampling
period which I denote here as
capital T. That will turn into
a slightly confusing parameter
shortly, and perhaps carried
over into the next lecture.
Hopefully, we'll get that
straighted out, though, within
those two lectures.
Remembering the issues of
sampling, the discrete time
frequency response, then since
the frequency responses the
Fourier transform of the impulse
response is related to
the continuous time impulse
response as I indicate here,
what this says is that it
is the superposition of
replications of the continuous
time frequency response,
linearly scaled in frequency
and shifted and
added to each other.
It's the same old sort of
shifting, adding, or aliasing
issue-- the same sampling
issues that
we've addressed before.
This equation will help us
understand what the frequency
response looks like.
But in terms of an analytical
procedure for mapping the
continuous time system function
to a discrete time
system function, we can see
that and develop it in the
following way.
Let's consider the continuous
time system function expanded
in a partial fraction
expansion.
And just for convenience, I'm
picking first order poles--
this can be generalized multiple
order poles, and we
won't do that here.
The same basic strategy
applies.
If we expand this in a partial
fraction expansion, and we
look at the impulse response
associated with this-- we know
how to take the inverse of
Laplace transform of this,
where I'm just naturally
assuming causality throughout
the discussion--
the continuous time impulse
response, then, is the sum of
exponentials with these
amplitudes and at these
complex exponential
frequencies.
Now, impulse invariance
corresponds to sampling this,
and so the discrete time impulse
response is simply a
sampled version of this.
The A sub k, of course,
carries down.
We have the exponential--
we're sampling at t equals
n capital T, and so we've
replaced that here, and then
the unit step to truncate
things for negative time.
Let's manipulate this further,
and eventually what we want to
get is a relationship--
a mapping--
from the continuous time to
the discrete time filter.
We have this step, and we can
rewrite that now as I show
here, just simply taking this
n outside, and we have e to
the s sub k capital T. Now this
is of the form the sum of
terms like A sub k times
is beta to the n.
We can compute the z-transform
of this, and the z-transform
that we get I show here--
it's simply A sub k over 1 minus
e to the s sub k capital
T z to the minus 1, simply
carrying this term or this
parameter down.
So we started with a continuous
time system
function, which was a sum of
terms like A sub k over s
minus s sub k-- the poles
were at s sub k.
We now have the discrete time
filter in this form.
Consequently, then, this
procedure of impulse
invariance corresponds to
mapping the continuous time
filter to a discrete time filter
by mapping the poles in
the continuous time filter.
According to this mapping, the
continuous time filter pole at
s sub k gets mapped to a pole
e to the s sub k capital T,
and the coefficients A
sub k are preserved.
That, then, algebraically, is
what the procedure of impulse
invariance corresponds to.
Let's look at how we interpret
some of this in
the frequency domain.
In particular, we have the
expression that tells us how
the discrete time frequency
response is related to the
continuous time frequency
response.
This is the expression that we
had previously when we had
talked about issues
of sampling.
So that means that we would
form the discrete time
frequency response by taking the
continuous time 1, scaling
it in frequency according to
this parameter capital T, and
then adding replications
of that together.
So if this is the continuous
time frequency response, just
simply an ideal low-pass filter
with a cutoff frequency
of omega sub c, then the
frequency scaling operation
would keep the same basic shape
but linearly scale the
frequency axis so that we now
have omega sub c times T. Then
the discrete time frequency
response would be a
superposition of these added
together at multiples of 2 pi
in discrete time frequency.
So that's what we have here--
so this is the discrete time
frequency response.
This looks very nice-- it looks
like impulse invariance
will take the continuous time
frequency response, just
simply linearly scale the
frequency axis, and
incidentally periodically
repeat it.
We know that for an ideal
low-pass filter,
that looks just fine.
In fact, for a band-limited
frequency response,
that looks just fine.
But we know also that any time
that we're sampling--
and here we're sampling
the impulse response--
we have an effect in the
frequency domain or the
potential for an affect
an effect that
we refer to as aliasing.
So in fact, if instead of the
ideal low-pass filter we had
taken a filter that was an
approximation to a low-pass
filter, then the corresponding
frequency scale version would
look as I've shown here.
And now as we add these
together, then what we will
have is some potential for
distortion corresponding to
the fact that these replications
overlap, and what
that will lead to is aliasing.
So some things that we can say
about impulse invariance is
that we have an algebraic
procedure--
and I'll illustrate with another
example shortly--
for taking a continuous time
system function and mapping it
to a discrete time
system function.
It has a very nice property in
terms of mapping, the mapping
from the frequency axis in
continuous time due to the
unit circle--
namely, to a first
approximation.
As long as there's no aliasing,
the mapping is just
simply a linear scaling of the
frequency axis, although there
may be some aliasing.
That means, of course, that this
method can only be used
if the frequency response that's
being mapped, or if the
system that's being mapped,
has a frequency response
that's approximately
low-pass--
it has to be approximately
band-limited.
Then what we have is some of
potential distortion, which
comes about because
of aliasing.
Also because of the mapping, the
fact that poles at s sub k
get mapped to poles at e to the
s sub k capital T, if the
analog or continuous time
filter is stable--
meaning that the real part
of s sub k is negative--
then the discrete time filter
is guaranteed to be stable.
In other words, the magnitude of
z sub k will be guaranteed
to be less than 1.
I'm assuming, of course, in that
discussion that we are
always imposing causality
on the systems.
To just look at the algebraic
mapping a little more
carefully, let's take
a simple example.
Here is an example of a system,
a continuous time
system, where I simply have a
resident pole pair with an
imaginary part along the
imaginary axis of omega sub r
and a real part of
minus alpha.
And so the associated system
function then is just the
expression which incorporates
the two poles, and I've put in
a scale factor of
2 omega sub r.
And now to design the discrete
time filter using impulse
invariance, you would carry
out a partial fraction
expansion of this, and that
partial fraction expansion is
shown below.
We have a pole at minus alpha
minus j omega r and at minus
alpha plus j omega r.
And to determine the discrete
time filter based on impulse
invariance, we would map the
poles and preserve the
coefficients a sub k, referred
to as the residues.
And so the discrete time filter
that we would end up
with as a system function,
which I indicate here--
and we have, as I said,
preserved the residue, and the
pole is now at a to the minus
alpha T, e to the minus j
omega sub r T. That's one term,
and the other term in
the sum has a pole at the
complex conjugate location.
If we were to add these two
factors together, then what we
would get is both poles
and a 0 at the origin.
In fact, then, the pole is
defined by its angle, and this
angle is e to the j omega sub
r capital T, and by its
radius, and this radius is e to
the minus alpha capital T.
Now we can look at the frequency
response associated
with that, and let's
just do that.
For the original continuous time
frequency response, what
we have is simply a resonant
character, as I've shown here.
And if we map this using impulse
invariance, which we
just did, the resulting
frequency response that we get
is the frequency response
which I indicate.
We see that that's basically
identical to the continuous
time frequency response, except
for a linear scaling in
the frequency axis, if you just
compare the dimensions
along which the frequency axis
is shown except for one minor
issue, which is particularly
highlighted when we look at
the frequency response at
higher frequencies.
What's the reason why those two
curves don't quite follow
each other at higher
frequencies?
Well, the reason is aliasing.
In other words, what's happened
is that in the
process so applying impulse
invariance, the frequency
response of the original
continuous time filter is
approximately preserved, except
for some distortion,
that distortion corresponding
to aliasing.
Well, just for comparison,
let's look at what would
happen if we took the
same example--
and we're not going to work
it through here carefully.
We're not work it through it
all, not even not carefully.
If we took the same example and
mapped it to a discrete
time filter by replacing
derivatives by backward
differences, what happens in
that case is that we get a
frequency response that
I indicate here.
Notice that the resonance in the
original continuous time
filter is totally lost.
In fact, basically the character
of the continuous
time frequency response
is lost.
What's the reason?
Well, the reason goes
back to the
picture that I drew before.
The continuous time filter had a
pair of resident poles close
to the j omega axis.
When those get mapped using
backward differences, they end
up close to this little circle
that's inside the unit circle,
but in fact for this example,
are far away
from the unit circle.
So far we have one useful
technique for mapping
continuous time filters to
discrete time filters.
In part to highlight some
of the issues, I focused
attention also on some not
so useful methods--
namely, mapping derivatives
to forward or backward
differences.
Next time what I would like
to do is look at impulse
invariance for another
example--
namely, the design of a
Butterworth filter, and I'll
talk more specifically about
what Butterworth filters are
at the beginning of
that lecture.
Then, in addition, what we'll
introduce is another very
useful technique, which has
some difficulties which
impulse invariance doesn't have,
but avoids the principal
difficulty that impulse
invariance does have--
namely, aliasing.
That method is referred to the
bilinear transformation, which
we will define and utilize
next time.
Thank you.